un panorama sur ce que vit vous
ressentent les enseignants français
c'est ce qu'a entrepris l'observatoire
de l'éducation de la fondation jean
jaurès un panorama en trois volets le
premier vient d'être publié il porte sur
la façon dont les professeurs appréhende
les questions religieuses et la laïcité
dans leur vie professionnelle
près de trois mois après l'assassinât de
sa malle pâtit ici à conflans sainte
honorine les questions religieuses dans
la vie scolaire serait selon l'anc est
de plus en plus source de tension il ya
d'abord cette autocensure en hausse pour
éviter les tensions 49 % des enseignants
soit près d'un sur deux se seraient déjà
auto censuré dans le renseignement des
questions religieuses ses 13 points de
plus qu'en 2018
il serait en revanche plus de la moitié
53% à avoir déjà observé des élèves
contester des enseignements au nom de la
religion que ce soit dans des matières
comme le sport les cours d'éducation
sexuelle ou encore dans des
enseignements portant sur la laïcité
là encore ce phénomène est en hausse + 7
points par rapport à une autre enquête
semblable réalisé il ya trois ans
concernant les formes de séparatisme
religieux et toujours selon cette étude
59% des professeurs y auraient été
confrontés dans leur établissement
actuel
cela concerne par exemple l'absence de
jeunes filles parfois sans aucune
justification à des cours de natation
le rejet de la viande au repas ou encore
le refus d'entrer dans certains lieux
religieux lors de sorties scolaires
après le meurtre de samuel pâti en
octobre dernier
des cérémonies d'hommage ont eu lieu
dans la plupart des établissements
scolaires ainsi un enseignant sur cinq
aurait été témoin de désapprobation ou
de contestation lors de ces cérémonies
34 % de ces faits se seraient déroulés
au sein du rep
le réseau d'éducation prioritaire enfin
plein interrogé sur le choix de samuel
pâti de montrer dans son cours les
caricatures de charlie hebdo
représentant le prophète 9% des
enseignants sondés estiment que ce
professeur d'histoire géographie a eu
tort ils sont 75% en revanche à soutenir
sa démarche 16 % préfèrent ne pas se
prononcer une timidité qui démontre bien
à quel point le sujet est devenu
sensible au sein de l'éducation
nationale
en ce début d'année 2021